les infirmières redescendre dans la rue
par deux démonstrations de masteel de
force ce matin mais une journée d'action
nationale pour demander des mesures
urgentes qui concerne essentiellement
les conditions de travail mot d'ordre
des infirmières ans dont la santé à la
santé il s'agit pour elle de revaloriser
cette profession qui souffre d'un manque
d'effectif une journée pour appeler
aussi aux français que très peu de
choses ont été réglés ewm était présent
ce symbole sous les fenêtres du
ministère de la santé
les infirmiers et infirmières de la
coordination qui se relayent six jours
et nuits en fonte à leur cinquième
ministre de la santé et pour les
manifestants rien n'est réglé depuis 88
ans rien n'a changé pour nous à part
quelques maigres aux augmentations
salariales ce qui n'était pas l'objectif
du mouvement infirmiers mais surtout
surtout dans les services il n'ya plus
d'effectifs c'est la situation d'extrême
urgence il manque aujourd'hui 15 lille
infirmières et infirmiers en france 1988
les infirmières sortent dans la rue
le mouvement surprend par son ampleur et
sa nature même la profession n'a pas
l'habitude de battre le pavé ni bonnes
ni nonnes ni connes distel celle qui
gagne 6 mn francs par mois en début de
carrière demandent une revalorisation de
leur profession et des effectifs
supplémentaires
les accords et 20 sont signés par
certains syndicats à la clé une hausse
de salaire entre 300 et 1500 francs par
mois selon les cas 1981 ondes les
infirmières ressorte rien n'est réglé
clame-t-elle les services explose faute
d'effectifs se sont alors les accords
durieux qui crée quatre mille nouveaux
postes
mais il ne sert à rien répondent les
infirmières de créer des postes sur le
papier il y a déjà des milliers de
postes vacants en france faute de
candidates à la profession seul remède
selon la coordination revaloriser le
métier en remontant le salaire à dix
mille francs pour attirer de nouvelles
candidatures
en attendant dans les hôpitaux beaucoup
d'infirmières créa l'état d'urgence
congé maladie maternité ne sont pas
remplacés elles ont parfois 35 malades
de nuit pour une seule infirmière elle
demande au gouvernement d'ouvrir
rapidement le dossier